في شرق اوكرانيا وبينما تراهن القوات
الروسيه على سقوط قريب لمدينه باخموت
المحاصره من ثلاث جهات تتسارع تطورات اخرى
تلقي بظلال من الغموض والشك حول الوضع
الميداني في باخموت اذ يحذر رئيس مجموعه
فاجنر الروسيه الخاصه
من ان الخطوط الاماميه الروسيه قرب
المدينه قد تنهار اذا لم تتلقى قواته
الذخيره التي تعاهدت موسكو بتقديمها رئيس
فاجنر يتساءل عما اذا كان الامر مجرد
بيروقراطيه عاديه ام انها خيانه على حد
قوله
ياتون الينا قائلين
ايها المدير هل من الممكن ان تصل قضيه
التاخير في الامداد بالذخيره اسماء
المسؤولين في وزاره الدفاع او الى من هم
في المناصب العليا كي يفهم الجميع في
روسيا سبب هذه المصاعب ماذا لو ارادوا
التخلي عنه والقول اننا اشرار ولذا لا
يقدمون لنا الذخيره
في هذا الوقت يبث الاعلام الروسي صوره عن
الحرب المنتهيه في مدينه ماريوبول
ماريوبول التي زارها وزير الدفاع الروسي
سرغي شويغو دون معرفه تاريخ هذه الزياره
لتفقد اعمال اعاده الاعمار في المدينه حسب
بيان للجيش الروسي مدينه ماريوبول حوصرت
ايضا لعده اشهر قبل ان تسقط في ايار مايو
من العام الماضي